morgen ist das Thema NATO-Mitgliedschaft
EU-Mitgliedschaft überhaupt kein Thema
ich glaube dass zum Thema
EU-Mitgliedschaft alles gesagt ist der
Weg der Weg wird frei gemacht aber es
muss eben trotzdem so sein dass die
Voraussetzung für einen u-bahntritt
erfüllt sein müssen daran können wir
auch nicht nachlassen finde ich dafür
ist die Europäische Union dann auch in
der Zukunft zu wichtig und die NATO
Mitgliedschaft auch dazu gibt es eine
Beschlusslage das wird zugegebener Zeit
entschieden werden die Tür ist ein Spalt
auch aber das ist jetzt nicht der
Zeitpunkt das jetzt zu entscheiden man
ist aufgeschlossen aber das nur dazu
muss man jetzt erstmal diesen Konflikt
diesen Angriff abwehren und dann in der
neuen Zeit muss man diesen Schritt genau
abwägen das ist keine Frage die man
jetzt mal eben so aus Solidarität trifft
weil er eben Wirkung hat das muss man
wirklich auch in aller Besonderheit tun
da muss man mit kühlen Kopf und heißem
Herzen entscheiden und nicht umgekehrt